sit down nice fish asses I'm tired I bet
you are
stick a fork in me Matt was it mad yeah
you're in the kitchen busting your
ourselves working hard to sell all those
people and John you out prancing around
like a sort of actors lissa thespian
thing isn't in it's not a theater but
you seem to enjoy it you have to force
yourself to like doing it I mean it's on
stage for three hours the problem that
the roosevelt elementary class the over
the own your own sure this place is
sinking because john refuses to take
anything seriously you love being an
entertainer don't you dare tell me that
that is hardly this whole [ __ ] thing
was put together for your fantasy well
that's kind of what this night is it is
entertainment we put on a show
you're pretending to be Sherlock Holmes
and upstairs were empty you in the [ __ ]
financially we're in ruins and if you
put the same amount of effort into
filling this place just one room booked
my would have made more profit than the
whole murder mystery and all that work
that went into it I mean this is insane
and you prance around like some [ __ ]
idiot while your wife is slaving away in
the kitchen
chillie care in the world apart for
yourself when you get a psychology
degree oh why don't you come and tell me
what's wrong with me here we go you
obviously think you are psychologist
Dennard again no I'm not in denial I
just don't know what you want it's only
your own [ __ ] stupidity - why we're
in the [ __ ] this bar well that is
probably true
so then man up and act responsible okay
I'm done with that
oh I've been with that in oh yeah no
just talk to my hand you know oh what a
[ __ ] idea ten years old you need to
grow up and stop running away from the
truth
this type return for your month are you
look so happy bunny
oh hello how are you party or one party
or what I'm not party for one good to
see you I'm Brian is that the same
congratulations the month you get a
bonus so you get a nice stage you know
I'm one of the only employees I've never
made the cut yet I see you just put
yourself in and what are the others
gonna say about that I'm one of them I'm
Brian stop aids yes come on
hey the other owners out third shot
honored you're the owner and you made
yourself employee a month yeah are you
the man with the g string the g string
reception's tell me to do that dancing
oh no that would probably be Kevin IOC I
don't know my booty is all too big to do
the last yes okay I was gonna say can't
wait to see that one I would love to
meet the other two the chef on the lap
dance early around other you only bring
them out yeah all right Kevin enjoy and
I we're all equal shareholders in this
business but it was my plan met you by
the hotel Oh Kevin Kevin Gordon good to
see when this is gone and all Joel so
you a lap dancer might have been some
left on fire I'm not a professional
maybe I'm a wild boy when I start
drinking I get a little stripper Dakshin
going on or the yellow rowdy and can be
the most fun that any young adult could
ever dream up
it's obviously the chef yes restaurant
manager and there's lap dancer
bar a bar manager so who's in charge all
three of us no such thing so who runs
the hotel who's in charge of the hotel
hotel manager job doesn't really entail
much
with free owners normally there's one
that takes the reigns and two other
silent
none of the sound have looked like an
owner well Gordon thinks we don't look
like owners but what what so owner look
like we bought the hotel nine months ago
right and you guys go back a long way
just kind of met each other 15 years ago
and we're confused whether it's the
three musketeers or Three Stooges
anyway I'm the whole quick bite to eat
it's been a long journey I'm excited to
taste the food thank you nicely thank
you very much Mike Gordon's in a lover
food
Joel works really hard everything he
puts out everything that comes out the
window it's a great product I can't
believe this hotel is owned by three
guys with a pink dining room Pink's the
new black well it's like a girl's
bedroom ghastly ghastly any specials on
today we had a fresh Alaskan halibut
with now that I'm talking to you I've
completely forgot no we had we had the
halibut with a well this is first time I
forget specials don't worry why don't
you check with the chef all right well
you have a brush to measure right yes
and I was a server to Russian manager
employ your mum a Nonna
yes all the above employer month I'm
gonna take that plaque back coming
rember the specials it smells like this
crap all over the floor probably cause
there's crap on the floor probably could
be what does that mean could be
my first shift here you were in the
bathroom and I think you had an accident
on the floor on the mat I mean yeah
there have been times when I have had
diarrhea but it doesn't happen very
often but no I didn't realize that there
was that problem right yeah
love the tie by the way thank you
everyone wears this Wow
how much are the outfits about 300 $400
$300 Everage you know they get their own
I mean there are their own dresses you
know oh you buy your own uniforms yeah
stop heads we do for many years and it
reminds them to not gain weight Wow so
who designed the place well my husband
and I and whose idea was it to buy it um
my husband she said wasn't yours it was
not my ideas actually very much against
it Wow why are you against it it was
very overwhelming I had two small
children but probably after I lost my
mind the first year I think we started
to get a hang of it and whose Austrian
are you fine husband south Austrian or
polish right I'm not nearly as exotic
I'm very American right and he's the
chef right so he runs the restaurant
kitchen and you run the inn correct and
whose idea was the violins on the table
mine where'd that come from that was
actually from an estate sale down the
street a dead man's violin yes why not
I don't want to sit across the table
with my wife and look at dead man's
violin well bit freaky no no what would
you rather look at when you see the
Vienna huh who's hurt my wife Oh your
wife yes but you have to have something
to make up that white space so what
would you suggest my wife
you're gonna put her on the table that's
what I'm a scandalous
I'm so [ __ ] confused dead man's
violin what about some flowers